hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar clinical value of measurable
residual disease assessment in multiple
myeloma i am sydney mcneill of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by scitognos to learn more visit
scitognos.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits i'd like to now
welcome our speaker dr juan
flores-montero post-doctoral researcher
university of salamanca salamanca spain
dr flores montero you may now begin your
presentation
well good day everyone and thanks a lot
for that kind introduction
it is a pleasure for me and also a
responsibility to be here today in this
webinar i would like to express my
gratitude to psychonauts for their kind
invitation and also to lapras for their
support from the organization of this
event
we'll be talking during the next minutes
about the clinical value of mrt
assessment immune stimuloma
and discuss how this is currently being
done
what for and also a glance what might be
coming around the corners
next
in between we will highlight some of the
matters that despite the available
evidence are still a source of
discussion
thanks for joining and i hope you find
all this information useful
before we start just let me show you for
a few seconds my potential sources of
conflicts for this presentation
and now without further delay without
going into much detail i will just start
with some background information to
situate ourselves in context
i will just briefly mention in the
general characteristic of myeloma
disease just to highlight the key
aspects used to establish the diagnosis
first of all accumulation of carnal
plasma cells in a bone marrow or other
tissues
secondly identification of monoclonal
components and third the occurrence of
well-known clinical manifestations that
are consequences of the previous two
aspects
additionally these and other
complemental parameters like sector
genetic profiles are investigated to be
able to identify the risk category of
any given patient
establishing the diagnosis and defining
the risk group just presents the
planning for a therapeutic integration
which aims to modify the natural history
course of the disease and provides
patients with a better quality of life
to prolong his or her survival and
possibly to offer even a cure
after the death error
after the therapeutic intervention takes
place we need to evaluate these effects
on the patient and this is to say we
need to investigate if the treatment was
effective and to quantify how effective
this was
minimal or measurable rational disease
strategies are designed to identify
remaining traces of the disease even if
they are subtle
after the therapeutic integration by
demonstrating demonstration depress the
persistence of the whole tonal cell
or their genomic material or signs or of
their activity on the possible sites of
accumulation
regarding therapeutics this has been a
very active field in the past decade
without ever growing number of drugs
approved and many other university
investigation to treat existing groups
of melanoma patients
consequence of the better understanding
of the disease biology we have moved
from a more classic group of drugs to
evolve new representatives of their
family but also to fully new agents with
noble mechanism of action
particularly those included in the other
category at the below are the bottom
part of the table
this category includes the newest
incorporation
here the biased specific antivirus and
the antibiotic drugs conjugate being
currently a very productive territory
many of these substances have been
explored initially as a single agent but
you know that most common scenarios
involve actually multi-drug for years
furthermore several different schemes of
similar combination of drugs that is to
say different doses number of cycles etc
are always on the revolution
clinical decisions and selection of
specific treatments are dependent on
many different aspects like patients and
disease characteristics prior treatments
or therapeutic resources availability
at the end every single approach has the
aim to achieve the most effective and
lasting tumor load reduction
the different therapeutic strategies
have become more and more efficient in
accomplishing this task with an
increasing number of patients reaching
deeper levels of response
nonetheless even within the group of
patients achieving best responses
clinical course is still here genius and
a group of them still relapse
one of the most evident causes of
relapsing is the persistence of
measurable disease there is a measurable
disease this is to say
that this part a portion of the disease
that we were not able to detect
this is the very reason pushing the
field forward to develop more efficient
and sensitive strategies to evaluate
this condition
the international myeloma workloading
group has refined in 2016 their criteria
to evaluate their responses to treatment
in multiple myeloma patients beyond
complete remission or extremist complete
permission to establish a common
language and to establish also a
reference frame to discuss and compare
the results
it's also pointed to the reference tools
available for this evaluation which are
the ones currently achieving achieving
the highest sensitivity
they have also outlined in this
recommendation how the results should be
interpreted
each one of these tools
approaches mrd assessment from a
different perspective in general terms
it shows two major different group of
strategies
on one hand the one that evaluates
inter-regularity involvement and that
includes next generation flow and next
generation frequency and on the other
those that search for the disease
outside the bone marrow
a side-by-side comparison of those
methodologies looking for the disease in
the bone marrow will allow to identify
their
perspective strong points and all sorts
of limitations
in general terms they are both extremely
efficient techniques that allow high
sensitive detection of mrt levels
while differences are evident when they
look into availability to some extent
applicability
time requirement results are generated
relative complexity and perhaps cost
one of the of the strongest points of
molecular based techniques is
sensitivity always perceived as superior
to that compared to that of proteins
nonetheless we need to understand that
in both cases for these high-end
methodologies the level of sensitivity
is very high and heavily dependent on
the amount of sample interrogated and
the quality of that sound
field either comparisons of bone marrow
reference techniques have been made
also they are many are actually right
now ongoing
here i show two examples the first one
at the initial evaluation of nds uh and
more recently the another from the
molecular team in the mathology
department in salamanca
results show
highly similar performance
even if they look at the problem from
different perspectives in most cases
from 75 to 86
their results are always concordant
between the two methods
regarding discrepancies and sensitivity
the evaluation favors one time each one
of the techniques but it's interesting
to point out that within the group of
cases possibly for just one of the
techniques at a time relapses were
always more frequent in the group of ndf
positive
next generation sequencing negative
results
it is also worthy to stress that we
think the double negative group some
progressions were also registered
the key aspect to stress here is that
both are very efficient techniques that
they are significantly and positively
correlated and more importantly that
they have both
similar clinical impacts
the same profile is also observed in a
similar comparison performed at the
memorial strong catherine census cancer
center where they have a single 10 color
cube high sensitive flow cytometric
approach with a similar performance
compared to ndf
in these comparisons overall concordance
is of higher than 90
and the fuses and the few discrepancies
this time favor mds results
the international aminoma working group
already indicated that mrd negative
status could be defined by using any of
the two approaches since the two are
alternative methodologies
as you may observe the clinical the
survival
cures are most extent should add up to
most expensive for impossible
thus the selection of one over the other
would probably correspond to local
availability degree of local expertise
cost of the practice and other practical
considerations
you probably all know ndf and the and
the most evident aspect of the
methodology that is the combination of
cellular targets investigated through
the test chronoplasma population and the
sample preparation protocol which
guarantees the sufficient amount of
cells to sustain the high sensitivity
claim
but i just wish to highlight now the
serious strong point of this methodology
which could be the one
of additional advantage over the
molecular methods
at the same time we get an efficient
answer on the principal questions that
is whether the station's mrd positive or
negative
based on the complementary analysis
strategies and tools
we double the amount of information
obtained from each sample and we
optimize the analysis type
thus the analysis intrinsically contains
complementary information that we are
all starting to observe and to establish
the clinical value
we can establish
the quality and representative of the
sample based on molecular and
bone marrow associated population
to identify related or unrelated and
metallurgic conditions coexistence with
the minimal residual disease
and to better understand the biology of
the receipt or finally or ultimately to
identify potential biomarkers with
prognostic significance
we have already mentioned that in spite
of the high sensitivity of home viral
mrd assessment some patients within the
mrb negative group still relax
these patients
show a very interesting profile since
for some of them at the time of relapse
the monoclonal protein was not
detectable or the bone marrow
chronoplasma cells could not be
identified
and particularly in this later group
without bone marrow involvement in this
cohort of patients from the spanish and
trials
five out of seven of them represent
represented extraordinary estrosis
plasmoditoma some of them
present already at diagnosis
this will be particularly an important
group of patients on which
the search for residual disease outside
the bone marrow is critical
in this regard similar to medullary
approach specificity results build
clinical relevant information and helps
to identify patients and significantly
increase risk of relapse in all
published data
even if
its overall prognostic significance
seems to be lower than the walmart
technique this doesn't make it make it
any less
relevant
imaging complements the evaluation of
patients within extramedullary disease
or diagnosis and in those patients with
no evidence of medullary disease that
follow up
so inserting this methodology in the
right place will within the follow-up
strategy will enhance the quality of
this prognostic information
the fact that
multiple melanoma mrt detection could be
now a trending topic doesn't mean that
this actually is something new
results have been generated for almost
two decades already
it is true that before this result was
generated with less sensitive approaches
nonetheless they have always clearly
pointed to the same direction
the site is this topic still rises some
discussions and some aspects remain
controversial there are many research
work meta-analysis and currently ongoing
with clinical projects specifically
designed a more among other objectives
to start providing answers to this
question
for example
is complete permission enough enough
well
it's it is perhaps surprising that this
question is even asked to say but it is
maybe the race still takes place around
this issue with the not inevitable
amount of scientists or clinicians
sustaining that mrd investigation are
not essential or that they remain as a
fully investigational tool
in contrast i believe that we are
agreeing
already for quite some time
that
in the first hand patients in cr are a
very heterogeneous group
with different clinical outcomes and
secondly that the current therapeutic
strategies are increasing the number of
patients in cr making this a more
populated category and even more
enterogen
but in any case mrda studies have always
shown no matter that no matter what
methodology is used or even if we use
different levels of sensitivity the
group of patients in cr can clearly be a
split in two groups with very distant
risk of relapse if we add a mrna
information of stuff on top of the
classic criteria
actually achieving cr without becoming
mrd negative is almost as fast as as
fast as achieving any
less quality response
actually
mrd measurement surpasses the risk
stratification and diagnosis with any of
the current available risk group
assessment approaches
even those based on risk and high risk
group
in phytogenetics
it is important to highlight that the
data also suggests that whenever
patients fail to achieve emerging
negative status the discrimination power
of these certification tools is retained
as a matter of fact there is a great
body of evidence showing that mrd always
has an impact on progression-free
survival and or overall survival
enough as as i just said despite the
mother the methodology used and even
when highly different operational
performance of these methodologies are
considered
actually several meta-analysis have
evaluated the relationship between mrt
and inspiration-free and overall
survival in an important number of
publications
involving a high number of patients
yet again demonstrating that in all
cases mrb negativity assessed by any of
this high-sensitive methodologies is
associated with prolonged progression
free survival or overall survival
as an example the largest methodologies
from last flight reported an
inter-adoption effect of mrd negativity
and progression on the risk of
progression and or death
providing even more
provost support for systematic mrd
investigation
i would like to highlight again that the
effects of permanent negativity is
independent of the sensitivity threshold
methodology diagnostic risk group
previous response criteria and the time
point of evaluation
but please be careful with
interpretation for example according to
last slide
can the scientific community just assess
dichotomic
mlb results
would say in positive versus negative
result is sufficient
well the answer will be no and to refer
your level of sensitivity should be
clearly stated in your report
if you decide to go for a less sensitive
method
that that will indeed be better than not
doing mrd at all but simply from a
quantitation point of view your mrd rate
could change from zero to health of your
patients if the higher sensitivity is
selected for example after consider
after consolidation
with the corresponding consequences for
the patient if clinical decisions are
taken based on these sensitive
thresholds
we need to encourage everyone
to aim to use the highly sensitive as
possible
as second best options might not be as
good enough for our patients
nine if we use information generated
from the highest sensitivity but
stratified the patients according to
different type of responses the impact
of
overlooking even very low amount of
residual disease on survival is clear
therefore becoming mrd negative is good
but the highest level of response are
the one actually discriminating the
patient at the very lowest
risk of relapse
as frequently introduced mrd negativity
surpasses the diagnostic risk definition
a diagnosis and therefore support the
concept of dynamic risk
i already mentioned that achieving mrd
negative overcomes poor prognosis
discrimination introduced by high risk
associated with phytogenitic normality
it might be negative high-risk patients
have similar progression-free survivors
or overall survival profiles than those
with a standard risk psychogenetics
it is also valid
the other way around also not as smart
as before the standard rate stations
with mrd positives do worse than the
standard breaks with mrd negative
making it evident that if mrd status is
not achieved cytogenetic risk
assessment retains its pronoun its
pronunciative values
but we can use mrd evaluations beyond
their prognostic power
for example to better compare and
understand the therapeutic interventions
mrd investigations
are one of the fastest most accurate and
reliable ways to compare results from
different treatment arms in clinical
trials
in the left part of the slide the
comparison between mrd grades after
system is induction regime
is shown
with an evidence of syrian performance
of procession methane talitha mine and
dexamethasone over other combinations
that advances advantage is clearly later
translated on survival differences
without mrd evaluation we will have to
wait until follow-up data is generated
to evaluating parts of each one of these
regimes on progression pressure value or
overall survival
which constitutes one of the strongest
points supporting the current efforts in
place directed to incorporate mrd
negativity as a valid endpoint for
clinical trials as the surrogate for
survival evaluation
we can use mrd information to
additionally evaluate what is the
specific impact of any given therapeutic
intervention
in this very recent publication from the
european myeloma network home on trial
they aimed to clarify the effect of
consolidation after induction and in ii
intensive intensification
mrd was only assessed in the supreme
court patient after the second
randomization and before the start of
maintenance
results show an overall benefit effect
of consolidation in the total cohorts of
patients nonetheless when we stratified
them according to mrd status for post
psychometry achieving mrd negativity
surpasses the effect of receiving
consolidation or not
indicating that in the mid positive
group the impact of political
consolidation is still observed
another concept introduced by
international melanoma working group in
2016
was regarding the value of single
measurement versus sequential evaluation
translated as sustained mrt negatives
in practice all the data showed so far
was based on single time point of
measurement
so the relevance of this mode of this
modality has already been assessed
more recently event studies have
investigated the value of sequential
measurements again in this recent one
from martinez's locus group from the
hospital to the supreme made
they have discriminated three group of
patients according to the level of mrd
in conservative measurements
and it is not surprising at least for me
that the one showing persistently
negative results and those in whom the
mrd level were progressively decreasing
where those patients had lower risk of
relapse
in line with this results results from
the asean trial
shows that the best survival profile is
observed for mrv and negative patients
particularly for those who were mrd
negative for more than 12 months
regardless the treatment are they were
included
nonetheless in mrd positive groups
associated with the charter progression
free survival and overall survival
patients that received that tumor must
display a significantly better profiles
associated with a higher quality of
response
two additional aesthetics have also
demonstrated keys in this case the
police and castle trials are 12 months
of sustaining activities it becomes
evident that these patients have
prolonged progression phrasal vitamins
in this study they have also showed that
sustained negativity is more frequently
occurring on the xylophony map
containing the gene
finally in this single center single arm
phase ii trial
in patients with continuous linear
needle mind maintenance mit was measured
yearly
and it's clearly observed that
persistence
of mrd negativity negative status at two
years was associated with the same
progression-free survival phase
in contrast
loss of mrd negativity or persistence of
multiples were associated with poor
profile
finally
when should we measure mrt and what
force in general most clinical trials
share most phases of the therapeutic
scheme
induction transplant if the patient
qualifies consolidation
in some trials and maintenance
mit assessment is frequently
investigated when the quality of
response needs to be evaluated
that is to say at the end of induction
and post transplant
beyond these two time points the matter
becomes more interesting
investigating mrd between faces info
about the contribution of each of them
to the overall patient response and
support easing experimental approaches
based on mrds
nonetheless in real life mrt results
continue to be mainly confined to this
experimental exploration and few already
considered mrt results to guide
clinical decision making
even if we all understand that mrd are
actually the most sensitive and
effective way to evaluate the depth of
response
many clinical trials are undergoing to
demonstrate utility and of more
personalized approach that incorporates
mrp guided decisions into everyday taxes
as an example
this slide shows currently active and
trials which include mrd-based clinical
decisions
based randomization
to wrap up this last point i graduated
here a very interesting data published
again by dr martinez
here they show that for patients outside
clinical trials in whom any kind of
adaptations of the therapy was
introduced after mrd assessment and
according to its results
a significantly prolonged survival bus
observed
and once again if the therapeutic
adaptation was made was made on the mrd
native group
it effect was not as important like for
the mrd-positive group of patients
finally a few words on what's next
the reason supporting the systematic
assessment of mrd
the indicator methodologies and specific
timings the researches
of the information the usage of
information generated
still needs to be defined so the
transitions to routine clinical practice
can finally happen
there is always room for improvement on
the right available to me
the high requirement for standardization
is not yet completed for all of them and
we must not forget that new players will
be coming on the field some of them are
already here
there seems to be a clear place for
continued and more frequent monitoring
but can we already do this with the
current approaches
well to answer some of these questions
we need to take a look into the role of
peripheral blood on whole money on the
whole monitoring strategy
loan overlooks principally because of
the lack of sensitivity methodologies
the current scenario is different and
present and present approaches can reach
high sensitive levels
but do not forget that the number of
donor plus muscles could be one to two
logarithmic decades slower in the bomb
and the peripheral blood compared to the
bone marrow
we know that bone marrow mrd monitoring
has certain limitations
patchy patterns on bone marrow
infiltration in patients with melanoma
which may be associated with sampling
bias
the fact that bone marrow aspiration is
an in basis of painful procedures
and the quality of samples that can that
may be affected by emotion and do not
allow for an accurate determination of
the tumor cell law
however peripheral blood evaluation can
be considered by means of using
techniques with an increased sensitivity
and provided that background evidence
demonstrates the presence of circulating
hormone plasma cells
and this presence steals clinical
relevant information
so can we use peripheral blood to
monitor residual disease in multiple
myeloma
well we know that uh once more depending
on the sensitivity of the selected
methods we can detect circulating tumor
plasma cells in the peripheral plot of
all multiple myeloma patient and
diagnosis using for example next
generation flow
detection and particularly the exact
quantification of circulating human
plasma cells holds clinically relevant
information as it helps to experience it
and god's versus more advanced stage of
the disease
it helps to detect angus patients with
an increased risk of progression and it
also allows to discriminate multiple
myeloma patients with more aggressive
disease behavior with a good correlation
with other risk assessment approaches
we can use this methodology to explore
the possibility of detecting those cells
also after treatment analysis is
clinical impact
there is a percentage of bone marrow
mrd-positive patients without evidence
of circulating tumor plasma cells
but seeing it from a different
perspective circulating tumor plasma
cells whenever present always means a
positive tomorrow
this is useful for a
in the clinical setting
when considered overall circulating
tumor plasma cell positivity it was
associated to an increased risk of
relapse as you can see in the upper left
side of the slide
in addition we could demonstrate that
circulating turmoil plasma cell positive
patients have a significantly more
prognosis that
than those bone marrow mrt positive and
circulating tumor plasma cell nets
so per se
circulating tumor plasma cells have
phonological
implications
finally in this group of patients
cerebral immunofication results have had
no additional impact overplanning our
dependentification power
of the circulating terminal plasma cell
established
furthermore the lowest risk was detected
on those patients who remain or became
negative in consecutive peripheral blood
measurements as you can see in the upper
right panel
so all of the above allowed to consider
then to include monitor and
monitoring on peripheral blood as a
relevant and informative tool in mrt
evaluation
potential application could be for
example better scheduling of bone marrow
mrt investigation
actually the group of doctor francis
francesca k has proposed a model to
select the mrd evaluation technology
based on clinical presentation and
diagnosis of the disease
importantly introducing a peripheral
blood evaluation systematically as the
initial step
you may have noticed in the last slide
that already a new methodology was
introduced that we haven't talked about
which has been under the spotlight in
the recent year
this is massive spectrometry mass of
spectrometry is a very promising
approach that that is rather easy to
perform and it increases significantly
the sensitivity of the classic
methodologies to the test monotonic
components
some results comparing mass effectometry
and other mrd methodologies sources are
starting to be shared particularly on
hematocology's music
in the last american society of clinical
oncology meetings
chris and collette shared the result
within the gm 2012
less than 65 years prior
where they compare massive spectrometry
versus next generation procytomy at the
time point where ngf was investigated
they reported highly comparable results
with around 20 percent of discordances
most of which correspond to ndf-positive
mass effect so much the united states
more importantly the pronunciation
impact of this measurement were almost
super impossible
nonetheless it has already been
highlighted that this technology bears
the same versions as previous
methodologies to the effective
monoclonal component that is this
monotonic component can be detected for
some time after the tumor cell has
disappeared due to prolonged half-life
of the protein
but on the other hand it may reflect
false negative ndf results because of
extra medullary importance
further investigation is warranted to
clarify the specific contribution and
clinical value of this technique and
define its place in the follow-up
strategy
as conclusion i will spread some ideas
to summarize all the presentations
evaluation of mrd within the bone marrow
can help to redefine conventional cr
definitions and further disseminate
different risk group of patients
high sensitive techniques are now
available and their sufficient
contributions have clearly been defined
additional confirmation of
extramedullary disease is very important
particularly in those patients with
extra medullary diseases diagnosis or
those that are mrd in the bone marrow
nerve
mrd is a very powerful and independent
and prognostic factor
reaching mrda status should be the aim
of therapy and this
category overcomes by diagnostic risk
certification and in every case it's
related to a prolonged survival
many clinical trials are going to
provide further evidence of clinical
activity of the mrdia person
in sequential monitoring monitoring and
alternatives to bone marrow mrd
investigation deserve further attention
and should be further characterized to
define a role in mrd assessment strategy
i would like to thank the um group of
people involved in the development of
all these works that i had shown now
and i will be available for questions in
the live session
thank you very much for your attention
thank you dr flores montero for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how do you deal with non-secretory
multiple myeloma that does not express
cd56 or cd117
well
thank you for that question
we must keep in mind that the city 66
and city 117 are not the only other
markers that are present in the in the
combination
so we may have
some other
informative markers to use in this in
this case uh most of the time uh the
abnormal plasma cells do not show a
unique or two uh only two abnormalities
but more than that
so uh i'm sure that we will have a
sufficient
information in the in the whole
combination to evaluate in this case and
be able to detect the abnormal plasma
cells in this case
great thank you our next question is do
you perform the mrd panel on every
follow-up case or do you have a less
sensitive panel
to screen for over relapse disease befo
before performing the mrd panel
well uh this is uh also very um
important questions and i think that uh
not always we get an enough information
from the samples and
when they are sent to our laboratories
so
to start with me for many times we do
not have the complete information as
well what exactly is the
going on or the moment of the evaluation
of the patient
so whenever we get a sample that it has
been treated we start with a high
sensitive
panel
meaning mdf to evaluate that sample
the
um only when if the sample is not being
evaluated for
follow-up or just two diagnosis then we
go for a less sensitive panel in the
diagnostic and identification
classification path
so the key the key
decision would be triggered by say
uniquely by the the information that
these patients have been treated in
advance
perfect thank you
our next question is do you use vs 38 in
your panels for dara patients
no we are not currently use it using it
we have evaluated that
specific marker locally and also there
have a few
papers or a few results also
produced by other researchers in the
within the scientific community
uh
in our hands and also in some of the
other results that has been shown that a
marker
is um
not that easy to
get completely
completely bright and good staining
its expression might be uh compromised
and and different according to the
sample preparation protocols and
processing that you perform on it so in
sometimes you can have a
presence of
a population of plasma cells that does
not sustain
for the for the marker
and this is something that we cannot
accept in the mrd
investigation
so we wanted to make sure that anything
that we use is uh working uh
as close to 100 of the cases as it could
be
so that's the reason
why we have not included that specific
marker
thank you our next question is the ngf
multiple myeloma mrd kit is not
validated by the fda for clinical trials
but ngs is
why so and what efforts are made to
change this
that's a very interesting and also
relevant question
um
for sure and true
the we are currently
undergoing the
putting the data together
to submit the
nges and methodology for approval for
both for the fda and also for the
european uh medical um
agency
uh and that is undergoing currently it's
just it was just a matter of uh time and
because uh nds
was let's say uh appeared first and
there was already uh some results
generated that validated the technology
uh first and then the flows recommended
technology but we are currently
organizing and validate and recover and
gathering the data putting the data
together to make these submissions
shortly as you know uh
in europe for example we are um
undergoing currently the
change in the legislation that um
makes us uh uh mandatory to have data
authorization uh rather soon to make uh
to be able to produce clinical results
and not only for nvidia but for all the
clinical applications
and uh so with this is an ongoing work
perfect thank you our next question is
do you think b2 microglobulin expression
on the surface of the abnormal plasma
cells might have an impact on the cart
cells treatment in multiple myeloma
i mean if the patients have skewed hla
because of inappropriate v2 expression
would this have an impact on the immune
synapse needed
for the correct functionality of the
cytotoxic antitumoral t cells
well this is a very interesting uh
question and and i would say
that
as far as i know
the levels of beta2 microglobulin are
just um
increased and
and there's no information that i know
of that points to the direction that
this protein is somehow altered in and
its constitution or in its function
so
it should it's just a reflection of the
tumor of mass
that the patient has not only for
myeloma but for other
diseases so it should not compromise uh
the
the synapse needed for a t cytotoxic
activity and also
in the in the case of uh it has been
evaluated in uh in the context of cardi
cells therapy because uh some people is
investigating the option to use a
allogeneic uh allergenic and car t-cells
uh to treat the patient and for sure we
will need to try to uh avoid
the graft versus horse disease in this
type of um
approaches and one of the approaches
evaluated is uh trying to
modify the expression of a
beta-2 microglobulin on the carcass so
it will be kind of a different uh um
scenario but as far as i know in the
expression of beta2 in the myeloma
plasma cell does not impact a function
of the cardiac cells
perfect thank you our next question is
to clarify you run the less sensitive
panel first
then if that's negative you do mrd which
markers are in your less sensitive panel
no
we run a less sensitive panel would mean
that we run
the panel for diagnostics always as
diagnostic and we know that even that
less sensitive panel is being asked
or named it's actually
as sensitive as 10 to the minus 4 so
it's very quite sensitive but it meant
for the diagnosis in which case we
expect to have a sufficient number of
normal plasma cells and a clear
population of abnormal plasma cells
present in in the sample
that
combination
a diagnostic is slightly different from
the ndf combination because it uh it's
meant to include
some prognostic markers for example here
we have beta2 microglobaline with that
which we have just uh mentioned and we
have another marker like u28
that it's also been associated with uh
abnormally expressed in myeloma in
myeloma cells and contributes to a
better determination of the abnormal
problem
but we do not
actually use this
panel
if the patient comes preparing before
the
detecting residual disease we always go
for the highest sensitive approach
because
we do not know in advance
uh whether the
the sample will be infiltrated or
or negative so we need to go for the
best
option we have in that
in those cases
great thank you
our next question is if you collect 20
million cells and analyze 10 million
nucleated cells what are the other
events that are excluded
well let's see if i understand this
correctly
i guess this question comes from the
sample preparation protocols and in
which we recommend to start with 20 and
20 million cells
which is the double of the number of
cells we recommend to acquire uh
systematically which is uh certainly 10
million and if this comes from the fact
that we always lose uh some cells during
processing
and and that cell loss could be as high
as 40
in some cases so to make sure that we
will have enough cells to
analyze to to reach that 10 million
cells and to be able to keep the highest
sensitivity that we can achieve
we recommend to go for
20 million to start a protocol with
so we in all cases will be able to
retrieve uh or recover 10 million cells
and at the end
it doesn't mean that you need to stop
at a million if you have more than 10
million you can certainly acquire
as many cells as as you have
in our hands it improves over time so uh
even if you start let's say using the
protocol
today you will see that you will get at
a million around 10 million cells and
as soon as you get more familiar with
the protocol you will start getting more
than 10 than 10 million and you should
certainly acquire as many cells as as
you have that will only
help you to increase your certainty and
your sensitivity levels
wonderful thank you our next question is
have you noticed any discrepancy in the
results of tube 1 versus two as the
first tube involves surface staining
while the second involves cells
permeabilization permeabilization
sure
uh
we
do have uh
observe some
differences i would say that those
difference are uh rather
minor in the sense that they there are
some
deviations in the in the
some of the markers including the
combination that not are affected by the
different
sample preparation protocols for tube
one and tube two
but since this is a youtube uh two tubes
approach it actually
it works as a
validation of the information that comes
from one or the other
so even if uh
most of the time the results are
totally compatible or not significantly
different between the two of them at the
end the conclusion is a um
form or a
produce taken into consideration their
results from the two tubes and making an
average of the few uh to make your final
your final conclusion so
we do see some differences
i would say that those differences
mainly in the expression of some
markers like the cv 19 for example
and a little bit of cd
138 that those differences are
muscles that are not dealing with the
numbers
of plasma cells detected
and that at the end you should make your
conclusion
considering the information coming from
the two tips together and that will also
increase
the certainty level of the results
thank you our next question is we found
a number of plasma cells in flow
significantly lower than bone marrow
than bone marrow core biopsy done at the
same time likely due to loss of plasma
cells in fresh sample
do you have the same experience does
this make an mrd negative sample
questionable
uh certainly we have had uh the same
experience this is a well-known uh
phenomenon that
occurs whenever we're comparing the
results coming from morphology compared
to the flow
cytometry results
but uh we know already for a long time
that that unbiased on the on the flow
and
this type of samples it's already
incorporated in the whole in the whole
approach what i mean is that even if you
get a different
number of plasma cells those numbers or
the level of the results are a
completely clinically relevant
meaning that even if you get a low
number then you make all your
results and your decisions based on
these numbers and
this number has been validated by the
clinic
by the clinical information so even if
they are less
they uh
preserve their uh clinically relevant
information they they provide
and um this also uh is the same for the
at the highest sensitivity level meaning
that if we cannot detect uh um the mrt
level with the with the combination it
means that for the highest sensitivity
with that combination and themselves are
absent
we
should keep in mind that there are not a
hundred percent of success rates for any
methodology and uh
we can and there is also no golden gold
standard for mrd detection and multiple
myeloma
so the only thing that we can do
is to compare with other uh available
techniques and and most of the time as
shown in the presentation that
they concordant results
rate is is pretty high and also we can
wait a little bit longer and wait for
the survival uh impact of the after
result and in those two aspects i would
say that we are pretty sure that
the
samples
coming from patients that at the end are
concluded it might be negative and we
are pretty sure that at the highest
sensitivity level those samples are
indeed negative
thank you our next question is for
clinical trials we often receive later
polls of marrow for mrd and cellularity
is not always as required have you
compared samples mock or real with
minimal cellularity to determine how
lloq is impacted based on cellular input
this is also a very important question
because i i do not know why um
this is still still happening we should
preserve the best sample we get for the
most informative techniques and
at minimal refugal disease evaluation
this is certainly not a
morphology
so we should try to convince uh the
clinicians and the
and the whoever is in charge of
taking the bone marrow examples to um
[Music]
send the most informative samples
that you can expect
to uh these are high sensitivity
techniques uh
evaluating my mrt we have indeed
evaluated the effects of emo dilution uh
both
let's say uh in silicon generated
material and also uh
actual uh dilution with preferred blood
and there are some other groups that
have been evaluating this as well
um
every all the information points to the
same direction that means that those
populations are are
highly linked to
to bone marrow samples and in peripheral
blood are the best indicators of the
quality of the samples of or the degree
of immobilization the problem is that
this is certainly true and beyond any
questioning for untreated samples but
when we get into the
treated
material
we should be aware that the
therapeutic integration taken and might
modify the way uh these uh populations
or
this population might be affected
differently
and uh
also the time point of evaluation might
have an impact on the on the
amount of this population that we can
that we can help observe
so the best thing that we can say now is
that you should
certainly actively look for these
populations and try to identify them
if you have them uh well represented and
and you have a reference a number for
them in in that specific um time point
and also that specific
regime it would really help you to uh
have a a good uh idea whether the sample
is immobilized or not
we are still actually also searching for
a and most more accurate and precise way
to define this but so far
this has not been
possible to have this approach rate
perfect thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
how many time points of mrd analysis do
you perform in your in your cohort of
patients and how many months between
each analysis
okay
for the work that we did at the
beginning to uh evaluate the performance
of the of the methodology we actually
did
all the time points that the clinical uh
team decided to to evaluate
uh in a more prospective uh
um
way
uh we uh
certainly are doing this at the end of
induction and after transplant
beyond those two
time points there is a
rather heterogeneous and it's on the
clinical
team shoulders to decide exactly the
time point of
evaluations and also or the the clinical
trial
objective and that's half a
decided when to evaluate the samples in
in advance
and i would say that this is also an and
not a question that has been actively uh
trying to be
answered by the current ongoing clinical
trials and we might have a better a
better answer to this question in
the near future
great thank you
thank you again dr flores montero for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor cytognose for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
goodbye thank you